ist jetzt ein 100 jahre altes rätsel
gelöst worden schon seit mehr als 100
jahren versuchen forschungsteams
weltweit das sogenannte voynich
manuskript zu entschlüsseln ein
schriftstück aus dem mittelalter das
voller ungelöste rätsel steckt worum
geht es inhaltlich und hat der inhalt
überhaupt einen sinn unklar ist zudem
auch die schrift und sprache des
dokuments entschlüsseln konnte das
wollen nicht wann es konnte bislang
niemand doch einen britischen forscher
will genau das ist jetzt gelungen sein
und das innerhalb von nur zwei wochen
links um science-fiction hier gibt es
täglich spannende science - abonniert
den kanal activity glocken und verpasst
nichts los geht's herzlich willkommen
und vielen dank für diesen super
spannenden themen vorschlagen der über
unsere telegramm community von timo kam
den link dazu findet ihr hier und amid
oder unten in dem video beschreibung da
gibt es tägliche news vor allem kind in
die videos vorher können themen
vorschlagen und diskutieren die schrift
ist geschwungen und die zeichnungen
erinnern an botanische astronomische und
anatomische zusammenhänge die rede ist
vom sogenannten wollen nicht manuskript
ein mittelalterliches schriftstück
besteht aus insgesamt 240 seiten mit
wirklich vielen illustrationen genannt
wurde es nach dem polen wilfried michael
wollen nicht ein büchersammler und
antiquar der das mysteriöse manuskript
dem jahr 1912 in die finger bekam er
fand das buch in einem landhaus ist
nicht von rom und dieser buch und sollte
ihn tatsächlich sein ganzes leben lang
nicht mehr loslassen
vorher hatte es wohl auch schon einmal
kaiser rudolf dem zweiten des heiligen
römischen reiches gehört und seit 1969
wird es in der bibliothek der yale
university auf vorrat viel mehr ist über
das wollen nicht manuskript aber auch
nicht bekannt auch seine entschlüsselung
gelang trotz intensiver 100 jähriger
forschung bislang nicht sowohl die
schrift als auch die sprache des
dokuments sind unbekannt die carbon
analyse des parlaments allerdings ergab
das ist wohl aus dem zeitraum von 1404
bis 1438 stangen muss es gab wirklich
unzählige entschließung versuche aber
keiner davon konnte den darauffolgenden
fachlichen prüfung standhalten mal wurde
das manuskript 11
türkisch mal als hebräer entschlüsselt
um das freundlich manuskript existieren
somit viele kontroverse theorien
beispielsweise das wollen nicht das
manuskript gefälscht haben soll es heißt
dass sogar entering und das fbi versucht
haben sollen
das mysteriöse rätsel zu knacken
erfolglos doch jetzt gibt es eine neue
erfolgsmeldung der britische
wissenschaftler gary chen von der
university of bristol schreibt in einem
artikel in der fachzeitschrift advanced
studies dass er das wollen nicht wann es
crypt entschlüsselt habe das was die
besten forschungsteams weltweit bisher
nicht geschafft haben sondern ihm sogar
innerhalb von zwei wochen gelungen sein
chef will herausgefunden haben dass eine
dominikanische nonnen die autorin sein
muss diese habe ein nachschlagewerk für
die königin von aragorn und deren
hofstaat geschrieben der linguistik an
der university brüssel behauptet dass
dies an landkarten in dem mysteriösen
skript zu erkennen sei auf denen könne
man eine rettungsaktion erkennen die die
königin von aragon anordnete um die
bevölkerung vor einem vulkanausbruch im
jahr 1444 zu renten inhalt nicht geht es
nach der analyse von shire um
kindererziehung sex fortpflanzung
kräuter heilmittel und teurer poetische
bilder dazu der forscher in einer e mail
es ist simpel es geht nicht um eine
interpretation die lösung braucht ein
alphabet eine schrift und eine sprache
jetzt ist es möglich jedes wort jede
formulierung und jedem satz zu nehmen
und folgerichtig zu besetzen inhalt
nicht gab es vor zwei jahren eine
ähnliche interpretation das wollen nicht
meine skriptes 2017 hatte der journalist
das männliche rückschlüsse auf die
illustrationen und den textbausteinen
gezogen und joshua ist sich ganz sicher
dass seine eigenen ergebnisse korrekt
sind hier habe sogar die sprache von
demnach handelt es sich um einen
vorläufer der heutigen romanischen
sprachen wie italienisch oder
französisch deshalb der name proto
romanisch obwohl die schrift
ausgestorben sei habe shire nicht nur
die symbole sondern auch die abkürzungen
eben auch das alphabet endlich
entschlüsseln können dazu schreibt er
die sprache zu identifizieren und das
geheimnis der schrift zu lösen
brauchte einfallsreichtum und querdenken
der text lala.com nord befindet sich
innerhalb des manuskriptes direkt neben
einem pflanzen wild und wird von shire
folgendermaßen übersetzt damit die
schwangerschaft das baby gutes wachstum
für eine normale geburt schafft je
rascher selbst ist also von seinem
erfolg überzeugt die restlichen fachwelt
dagegen nicht direkt nach seiner
veröffentlichung hagelte es kritik
beispielsweise von der amerikanischen
mittelalter forscherin lisa fake in
davis die am 15 mai 2009 10 twitterte
sorry folks protons language ins lot of
things ist just aspiration übersetzt
also sorry leute aber dieses foto
romanisch gibt es nicht das ist unsinn
auch die romanistin sandra hayek von der
universität in götting bezweifelt dass
fischeier wissenschaftlich sauber
gearbeitet
sie schreibt auf ihrer webseite für die
existenz einer einheitlichen brutto
romanischen sprache gibt es keine
wissenschaftlichen belege die ältesten
in romanischen sprachen überlieferten
texte seien aus dem neunzehnten
jahrhundert und diese seien überhaupt
nicht ähnlich zu dem nun von shire
rekonstruierten text auch der deutsche
computerlinguisten hermes zweifel dass
ergebnissen denn die muster in den
texten des wollen nicht manuskript es
weichen erheblich von anderen bekannten
natürlichen sprachen haben somit
schließt hermes aus dass es sich um die
verschriftlichung einer natürlichen
sprache an denn er geht davon aus dass
es sich eher um eine art kunst sprache
handelt das manuskript ist nicht zu
knacken weil jemand einfach etwas zu
papier gebracht hat das keinen sinn
ergibt vielleicht ein psychisch
gestörter vielleicht ein kind oder
jemand der das manuskript teuer verkauft
hat auch die university bristol hat den
aufsatz von jake shia jetzt erst einmal
zurück genommen um zunächst noch einmal
ausführlich zu prüfen
ich finde so etwas ja mega spannend vor
allem wenn man den prozess des trailers
also versuch und irrtum öffentlich
verfolgen kann aber geoglyphen wurden
auch irgendwann entschlüsselt die
spannung bleibt physikalisch unrettbar
quantenkryptographie sehr sehr cooles
video also hierüber wirklich nicht
entschlüsseln
fotografie anklicken anschauen und dem
megacoolen kanal doktor watson
abonnieren bis dann bleibt dran